I think they overplayed their hand
though because what happens subsequently
is they said trans women are women you
have to legally recognize that we are
literally women otherwise you're of
bigot otherwise you're someone deserving
of cancellation they said we want to
play in women's sports we want to go
into women-only areas we want to go into
women's changing rooms we saw a case
like that in Los Angeles a couple of
years ago a man with a semi erection in
a woman's Cajun room in front of in a
place where women and girls undress and
that's the point at which I think lots
of people said okay hold up what's
happening here because what is presented
as a movement for Freedom looks
increasingly like an encroachment into
the hard-won freedoms of womankind